At some point, merely every one of us has experienced the uncomfortable sensation of feeling out of place. Maybe it was in your middle school cafeteria, or during your first few weeks on an unfamiliar college campus, or in a job interview with a potential boss whom you desperately wanted to impress. We all remember what it feels like to hear that questioning voice in our head, wondering what everyone else is thinking of us and whether we really belong there. The desire to belong is a fundamental part of human nature, according to psychologists. And when people feel out of place, when their sense of belonging is threatened, then that discomfort and self-doubt can have far-reaching effects.
在某些时候，几乎我们每个人都经历过格格不入的不适感。也许是在初中的食堂里，也许是在陌生的大学校园里度过的最初几周，又或者是在面对你极力想要留下好印象的潜在老板进行的求职面试中。我们都记得听到脑海中那个充满质疑的声音是什么感觉，它在琢磨着别人都在怎么看自己，以及自己是否真的属于那里。心理学家指出，渴望归属感是人类天性的根本部分。而当人们感到格格不入，当他们的归属感受到威胁时，这种不适感和自我怀疑就会产生深远的影响。
In fact, according to some psychologists, threats to belonging help drive problems as varied as racial and gender achievement gaps, political polarization, and even physical health problems. So why is belonging so important? Are there ages or life stages when belonging matters most to us? How are social media, remote work, and other technology-driven changes affecting our sense of belonging? How does the need to belong figure into the clubs we join, our political affiliation, and even where we choose to live? And what tools can teachers, employers, and others use to increase people's sense of belonging, especially for people who are most at risk of feeling like outsiders?
事实上，根据一些心理学家的说法，对归属感的威胁助长了形形色色的问题，比如种族和性别成就差距、政治极化，甚至是身体健康问题。那么，为什么归属感如此重要？有没有哪些年龄段或人生阶段，归属感对我们最为重要？社交媒体、远程办公以及其他技术驱动的变化是如何影响我们的归属感认知的？对归属感的需求又是如何在我们加入的俱乐部、我们的政治倾向，甚至是我们的居住选择中体现出来的？教师、雇主和其他人可以使用哪些工具来增强人们的归属感，尤其是对于那些最容易觉得自己是外人的人群？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jeffrey Cohen, a professor of psychology and the James G. March Professor of Organizational Studies in Education and Business at Stanford University. He studies the processes that shape people's sense of belonging and the threats to belonging that people face at school, at work, and in health care. settings. He also designs what he and others call wise interventions that aim to increase belonging
欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是杰弗里·科恩（Jeffrey Cohen）博士，他是斯坦福大学的心理学教授，同时也是教育与商业组织研究的詹姆斯·G·马奇（James G. March）教授。他主要研究塑造人们归属感的过程，以及人们在学校、职场和医疗环境中面临的对归属感的威胁。他还设计了他和其他人所说的“明智干预措施”，旨在增强归属感
and help solve social problems such as racial and gender achievement gaps. His new book is called Belonging, The Science of Creating Connection and Bridging Divides. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Cohen. It's my pleasure to be here. Thank you so much. Let's start with a line from your book. You wrote, A sense of belonging isn't just a byproduct of success, but a condition for it. In school, work, homes, healthcare settings, negotiations, politics, community policing, and virtually every domain in which humans deal with other humans. We'll get into the details later, but first let's talk broadly. Why is belonging so important and, as you say, so necessary for success?
并帮助解决社会问题，例如种族和性别成就差距。他的新书名为《归属感：创造连接与弥合分歧的科学》（Belonging, The Science of Creating Connection and Bridging Divides）。非常感谢您今天能来参加节目，科恩博士。这是我的荣幸，非常感谢。让我们从您书中的一句话开始。您写道：“归属感不仅仅是成功的副产品，而是成功的条件。在学校、工作场所、家庭、医疗环境、谈判、政治、社区警务，以及人类与其他人打交道的几乎所有领域中都是如此。”我们稍后会讨论细节，但首先我们来广泛谈谈。为什么归属感如此重要，并且如您所说，对成功如此必要？
As a social species, we've evolved to be exquisite. attuned to whether or not we belong in our group, with our tribe, with our kin, and that includes our fictive kin. As human beings were physically pretty helpless, especially when we're first born, but compared with other animals, we really don't have much going for us, except for one superpower. And that is the ability to work together to solve common problems. I mean, of course, there's other superpowers that we have, language, thought, consciousness. But the ability to learn and work together is one of the most important assets we have as human beings,
作为一种社会性物种，我们在进化过程中变得极其敏锐，能够敏锐地察觉到自己是否属于我们的群体、我们的部落、我们的亲属，这其中也包括我们的拟亲属。作为人类，我们在生理上其实相当无助，尤其是在刚出生的时候；与其他动物相比，我们确实没有什么优势，除了一个超级超能力。那就是共同努力解决共同问题的能力。我的意思是，当然，我们还有其他的超能力，比如语言、思想、意识。但是学习和共同工作的能力是我们作为人类拥有的最重要资产之一，
which enable us to survive, thrive, take over the planet. And it's that fundamental concern about belonging to a larger, group, being accepted in that group and having something to contribute to that group that motivates so much of our day-to-day thought, feeling, and action. So what happens psychologically and even physically to people who lack that feeling of belonging? I've been thinking about this. I think that you really start to appreciate the importance of a sense of belonging when
这使我们能够生存、繁衍并占领地球。正是这种对属于一个更大的群体、被该群体接受并在该群体中有所贡献的根本关切，激励了我们日常的大部分思考、感觉和行动。那么，对于缺乏这种归属感的人来说，心理上甚至生理上会发生什么呢？我一直在思考这个问题。我认为，你只有在归属感被剥夺时，才会真正开始体会到它的重要性。
it's taken away. For many of us, it's so easy to take that for granted. the things that I like about, for example, traveling abroad or going to a strange town that I'm unfamiliar with is kind of being jarred out of that familiar feeling of, hey, I know what I'm doing here. I feel like I'm part of the in crowd. Oftentimes when we're in a novel situation, a stranger in a strange land, we suddenly feel, oh, this is what it feels like not to feel like I belong. And for a lot of people, for a lot of members of historically underrepresented groups or stereotypes, type groups, that feeling is a continual reality in many of our institutions. The answer to your
对于我们许多人来说，把这些认为是理所当然是太容易了。我喜欢出国旅行或去一个我不熟悉陌生小镇的原因之一，就是打破那种“嘿，我知道我在这里做什么，我觉得自己是核心圈子的一员”的熟悉感。通常情况下，当我们处于新颖的环境中，做一个异国他乡的陌生人时，我们会突然感觉到，哦，这就是没有归属感的感觉。对于许多人来说，对于历史上代表性不足的群体或刻板印象群体的许多成员来说，这种感觉在我们许多机构中是一种持续的现实。对于你提出的
question of what is it like to feel like you don't belong is uneasy, people feel anxious. And one of the best demonstrations of the effects of being ostracized comes from work by Kip Williams, where he has people passing a ball using an avatar. It's a kind of computer game. They pass a ball. a kind of computer game of catch to other avatars in a kind of video game. And all of a sudden, the avatars, the other two avatars, start passing the ball amongst themselves excluding you. And unbeknownst to the participant, these two other avatars are actually pre-programmed entities. And the effects of that, as Kipp Williams says, is pain, social pain. And in fact, the same regions associated with the experience of physical pain are activated when people experience
关于“觉得自己不属于这里是什么感觉”的问题，答案是不安，人们会感到焦虑。关于被排挤效果的最佳证明之一来自基普·威廉姆斯（Kip Williams）的研究，他让人们使用虚拟形象传球。这是一种电脑游戏。他们传球。一种在视频游戏中把球传给其他虚拟形象的抛接游戏。突然之间，那些虚拟形象，另外两个虚拟形象开始在彼此之间传球，把排挤在外。而在参与者不知情的情况下，这两个虚拟形象其实是预先编程的实体。正如基普·威廉姆斯所说，这种做法的效果是痛苦，即社交痛苦。事实上，当人们经历
social ostracism. So it seems like we're wired in such a way to feel not just biological threat, but that kind of reputational threat, that threat to our social image when we're ostracized in a way that's biologically really similar to the experience of pain. And it's interesting that people can get upset even when an avatar stops throwing a make-believe ball at you. I mean, it seems so simple. That's right. It's surprising. The triviality of the experience, the big impact of a trivial experience to just how powerful the need and the mode it is. Are there ages or stages in life when the need for belonging looms largest? You know, we think about middle schoolers and teens desperately trying to fit in with their peers, for instance, but
社交排挤时，与体验身体痛苦相关的大脑区域会被激活。所以，当我们被排挤时，我们的神经布线似乎不仅会感受到生物学上的威胁，还会感受到那种声誉上的威胁，对我们社会形象的威胁，这在生物学上与痛苦的体验非常相似。有趣的是，甚至当一个虚拟形象停止向你抛出一个假想的球时，人们也会感到沮丧。我的意思是，这看起来太简单了。没错。这令人惊讶。微不足道经历的微不足道，却对巨大经历产生重大影响，这恰恰说明了这种需求和模式是多么强大。在人生的某些年龄或阶段，对归属感的需求是否最为迫切？你知道的，例如，我们会想到中学生和青少年拼命试图融入同龄人，但
not as much about adults' need for belonging. So when are the times? when the need to belong is most acute? The need to belong is most acute, of course, in the early years when we're first born, the importance of early attachments has been heavily researched by pioneers of the 20th century, such as John Bolby, Mary Ainsworth. In addition, though, it's important throughout the life course, but especially during certain phases of our life, I would say pre-adolescence and adolescents are key stages where we're trying to figure
对成年人的归属感需求却关注较少。那么，什么时候是对归属感的需求最为迫切的时期？当然是在我们刚出生的早期岁月里，对归属感的需求最为迫切，20世纪的先驱者如约翰·鲍比（John Bowlby）、玛丽·爱因斯坦（Mary Ainsworth）对早期依恋的重要性进行了大量研究。不过除此之外，它在整个人生历程中都很重要，但在我们生命的某些阶段尤其如此，我想说，前青春期和青春期是我们试图找出我们在
out our place in the wider world. So that's one point that I think often gets a bit of short drift, but that now with the kind of crises in teen health, teen anxiety, depression, suicidality among boys, cutting among girls, I think there's going to be, and there is increasing attention to the importance of connection and belonging during the adolescent years. In fact, one of the big predictors of teen reckless behavior and mental illness or mental health problems is a sense of connection, both in school and in home. Those two perceptions that I belong at school and I belong in my home turn out to be among the strongest predictors and large representative samples of teen reckless behavior, risk behavior, and mental health issues. So the teen years are
更广阔世界中的位置的关键阶段。所以这是我认为经常被有些忽视的一点，但现在随着青少年健康危机、青少年焦虑、抑郁、男孩自残、女孩割腕等现象的出现，我认为将会并且正在受到越来越多的关注，即在青春期建立联系和归属感的重要性。事实上，青少年鲁莽行为和精神疾病或心理健康问题的一个重要预测指标，就是学校和家庭中的连接感。这两种感知——“我属于学校”和“我属于家庭”，在关于青少年鲁莽行为、风险行为和心理健康问题的大型代表性样本中，被证明是最强的预测指标之一。所以青少年时期是
important. But as you said in your opening remarks, I think it's something that we all encounter, and it may not be really marked by chronological age as much as it is by transitions. So I think in these liminal stages of life where we're making a transition from one social world to the next, a new school, a new job, a new role as a parent or caregiver, whatever the case may be, we experience acute doubts or we can. We are susceptible to what Greg Walton and I call belonging uncertainty, where we're just wondering, do I belong here? Do I want to belong here? And can I make it? Do other people accept me here? So I think it's important throughout the life course, but especially in the early years, in adolescence, and transitions, at major transitions.
很重要的。但正如你在开场白中所说的那样，我认为这是我们所有人都会遇到的事情，它可能不像按日历年龄划分那样明显，而是更多地由过渡期来标记。因此，我认为在这些处于边缘状态的人生阶段中，我们在从一个社会世界过渡到另一个社会世界时，比如一所新学校、一份新工作、作为一个父母或照顾者的一个新角色，无论具体情况如何，我们都会经历强烈的怀疑，或者我们可能会经历。我们容易受到格雷格·沃尔顿（Greg Walton）和我所说的“归属感不确定性”的影响，我们当时会想：我属于这里吗？我想属于这里吗？我能成功吗？这里的人接受我吗？所以我认为它在整个人生过程中都很重要，但在早期、青春期和重大转折点尤其重要。
A lot of your work has focused on how very brief interventions that increase people's sense of belonging can have surprisingly powerful and long-lusting effects on, for example, student achievement. You've looked at this in the context of using these interventions to help close racial and gender achievement gaps. Can you talk about that work? How do these wise interventions, as you call them, work? Well, the term wise intervention was actually has a history. Greg Walton has applied it to the idea of, to describe interventions that are
你的许多工作都集中在如何通过非常短暂的干预来增强人们的归属感，从而对学生的学业成绩产生出乎意料的强大且持久的影响。你曾在利用这些干预措施帮助缩小种族和性别成就差距的背景下探讨过这一点。你能谈谈这项工作吗？你所谓的这些“明智干预”是如何发挥作用的呢？嗯，“明智干预”这个术语其实是有历史的。格雷格·沃尔顿曾将其应用于这样一种理念，即用来描述那些
psychologically attuned to people's sort of thoughts and feelings that are kind of precisely targeted at underlying psychological processes. But the term actually goes back to Irvin Goughman, my all-time favorite sociologist. And he borrowed the idea that the term Y is from the gay subculture of the 1950s. And among the gays, the term Y is referred to straight people who were kind of in the know, who understood the full humanity of gay people in spite of their wider stigmatization by the rest of society. So we use the term Y similarly in a lot of our research to describe interventions that
对人们的思想和情感具有心理适应能力的干预措施，这些措施精准地针对潜在的心理过程。但这个术语实际上可以追溯到我最喜欢的社会学家欧文·戈夫曼（Irvin Goffman）。他从20世纪50年代的同性恋亚文化中借用了“明智（wise）”这个词。在同性恋群体中，“明智”指的是那些知情、尽管同性恋受到社会其余部分更广泛的污名化，但仍理解同性恋者作为人的完整性的异性恋者。因此，我们在许多研究中也类似地使用“明智”这个词来描述这样一些干预措施：
reassure people of their belonging, even when simultaneously people are being discriminated against stereotyped, susceptible to larger messages of degradation. How do you do that in day-to-day social life, convey that a person is fully seen? And as that sort of study that I described with Kip Williams, one of the big triggers to feeling like you don't belong is feeling like you're not seen, right? Those two avatars are passing the ball back and forth, as if I'm invisible. visible, not here. So what wise interventions do is to send the message, often in word, but sometimes indeed, that you are seen. And just to take one example, in some research that I did with my colleagues, Claude Steele, Lee Ross, David Jaeger, Valerie Purdy Greenway, on the problem
即使人们同时受到歧视、刻板印象的影响、容易受到更广泛的贬低信息的侵害，这些干预措施也能重新向人们保证他们的归属感。你如何在日常社会生活中做到这一点，传达出一个人被完全看见的信息？正如我在描述基普·威廉姆斯的那个研究所表明的那样，觉得你没有归属感的一个巨大触发因素就是觉得自己没有被看见，对吧？那两个虚拟形象把球传来传去，就好像我是隐形的，不在这里。所以“明智干预”所做的是发出信息，通常用语言，但有时也通过行动，即你是被看见的。仅举一个例子，在我与同事克劳德·斯蒂尔（Claude Steele）、李·罗斯（Lee Ross）、大卫·耶格尔（David Jaeger）、瓦莱丽·珀迪·格林威（Valerie Purdy Greenway）共同开展的一项关于
of how to give good critical feedback across racial lines. One of the things that we found works really well when giving feedback, say a white teacher is giving feedback to a black student where there is this sort of possibility that the feedback could be seen as untrustworthy and as a sign that I'm not being fully seen and I'm being stereotyped. One of the things we found that works really well, a good wise intervention, is to say that this criticism that I'm giving you is a sign of my high standards. And I'm giving it because I have high standards and because I believe in your potential to reach them. When the criticism was just given in this way, black students responded to the same feedback as positively as did white students. They were even slightly more motivated to revise
如何在跨种族群体中给予良好的批判性反馈的研究中，我们发现，在给予反馈时，比如白人教师给黑人学生反馈时，这种反馈可能会被认为不可信，并被视为我没有被完全看重以及我被刻板对待的信号，在这种情况下，有什么方法效果非常好。我们发现效果非常好的一种方法，即一个好的明智干预，就是说我给你的这个批评是我高标准的标志。我给出它是由于我有高标准，并且我相信你有能力达到它们。当批评只是以这种方式给出时，黑人学生对同一反馈的反应与白人学生一样积极。他们甚至有稍强的动力去修改
their work. And one of the amazing things about these wise interventions that we're still trying to get our heads around is that sometimes they can set in motion a virtuous cycle such that even days, weeks, years later, you see the after effects. So in the case of wise criticism, when we had teachers deliver this wise feedback to their students in middle school. These were seventh graders. Not only did the kids where the kids more likely to revise their essays, but the following year, they reported more trust in their teachers. They were less likely to get into disciplinary trouble. And then years and years later, just as a result of this one experience of feedback, they were more likely to make it to college, 20% percentage points more likely to make it into college.
他们的作业。关于这些明智干预措施，有一件令人惊奇的事情，我们至今仍在努力理解，那就是有时它们可以引发良性循环，以至于在几天、几周、几年后，你仍然能看到后续效应。所以在明智批评的案例中，当我们让老师在中学向学生传授这种明智的反馈时。这些是七年级的学生。孩子们不仅更有可能修改他们的论文，而且在第二年，他们对老师表现出更多的信任。他们更不容易惹上纪律麻烦。然后，多年之后，仅仅因为这唯一一次反馈经历，他们更有可能上大学，进入大学的可能性高出20个百分点。
So what's interesting about these wise interventions isn't so much the power of them. The power of them is really interesting. What I see them as demonstrating is just how much untapped potential there often is in individuals that we just don't see. That's just waiting there to be tapped into through the right change in the situation. Is this research making its way into teacher training? I mean, it sounds incredibly valuable, and I know that there's a long time between research and psychology and application in the real world. It is.
所以关于这些明智干预措施，有趣的地方不在于它们的力量本身。它们的力量确实很有趣。在我看来，它们展示的是，在个体身上往往存在着那么多我们根本看不到的未被发掘的潜力。这些潜力正静静地等待着通过对环境做出正确的改变而被激发出来。这项研究是否正在进入教师培训领域？我的意思是，这听起来非常有价值，而且我知道心理学研究与现实世界应用之间存在很长的时间差。是的。
It is. Over the past, I didn't know it would take this long, but it takes about two decades. So, over the past two decades, it's made its way into a lot of schools of education. One of my positions is in a graduate school of education, so I assume since they invited me there, they were interested in this. in this kind of work. There's also some lovely work by Christine Davis Rubies, demonstrating how you can teach teachers to be responsive to the dynamics of the classroom and to these sort of psychological concerns that students have that's had really positive results.
是的。在过去，我不知道这需要这么长时间，但这大约需要二十年。因此，在过去的二十年里，它已经进入了许多教育学院。我的职位之一就是在教育研究生院，所以我假设既然他们邀请我去那里，他们一定对这种类型的工作感兴趣。克里斯蒂娜·戴维斯·鲁比斯（Christine Davis Rubies）也做了一些非常棒的研究，展示了如何教导教师去适应课堂动态以及学生们的这些心理关切，这取得了非常积极的成果。
So I think that more and more these ideas are percolating into schools of education. The question I always come back to is, well, what is the big lesson of this research? And one of the things I try to emphasize in my book is I think it's a mistake to think that the big lesson is the interventions. Like you do, you just say, I have high standards and believes that you can make it and magic happens. Or we do some work on what's called values affirmations where you have kids reflect on their core values and bang, suddenly some of them start to excel at school in ways that they hadn't
所以我认为这些理念正在越来越多的教育学院里渗透。我经常回过头来思考的问题是，这项研究的核心教训究竟是什么？我在书中试图强调的一点是，我认为把核心教训归结为干预措施本身是个错误。好像你只需要说，我有很高的标准并相信你能成功，然后奇迹就发生了。或者我们做一些关于所谓的价值观肯定的工作，让孩子们反思他们的核心价值观，然后“砰”的一声，其中一些人开始以他们以前没有过的方式在学校里表现优异
before. They break free of a harsh history. The lesson isn't so much about the power of any wise intervention process. per se, as much as it is about the power that we all hold as engineers of one another's situations to bring out one another's best. And that's one of the things I try to really emphasize in my research and the talks I give in the book is just how much of a superpower we have in our day-to-day encounters to warp situations, shape situations in ways that tap into untapped potential. Of course, you need the right
他们摆脱了严酷的历史。这个教训与其说是关于任何明智干预过程本身的力量，不如说是关于我们所有人作为彼此情境的塑造者所拥有的力量，能够激发出彼此最好的一面。这也是我在我的研究、演讲以及书中极力想要强调的事情之一，那就是我们在日常交往中拥有多么巨大的超能力，去扭曲情境、塑造情境，从而挖掘出那些未被发掘的潜力。当然，你需要正确的
way of altering situations to bring about that kind of change. But the research suggests that it is possible to bring about more change than we often think. And we hold some power as educators, as parents, as coaches, as mentors to do that day to day, day and day. A lot of times we're often doing it and we have no idea that we're doing it. That's one of the tragedies being an educator is that you often have a powerful impact, but don't see it. You use the word affirmation a moment ago, and I know that's an area where you've done some work. Can you explain? how that works and the impact that it has on kids who learn affirmation, who learn how to use this. Yeah. Well, this is some work that Julio, my close colleague, Julio Garcia and Valley
改变现状以带来这种转变的方法。但研究表明，能够带来的改变比我们通常想象的要多。作为教育工作者、父母、教练、导师，我们每天都在日复一日地掌握着这种力量。很多时候，我们在不知不觉中就在这么做。作为一名教育工作者，悲剧之一在于你常常产生深远的影响，却看不到它。你刚才用了“肯定”这个词，我知道这是你做过研究的领域。你能解释一下这是如何运作的，以及它对那些学习肯定、学习如何使用这一技巧的孩子产生的影响吗？是的。这是我的亲密同事胡里奥·加西亚（Julio Garcia）与瓦利
Purdy Greenway and Jonathan Cook and I did many, many years ago, at least we started many years ago, we're still doing it. And it drew a lot on Claude Steele's self-affirmation research, which basically says that one of the things that people work hard at, in their lives is maintaining an image of themselves as globally competent, people with moral and adaptive adequacy. And sure, people want to feel that they have self-integrity. And one of the hard things about being a member of a historically stereotyped or stigmatized groups, such as an African-American or Latinx student in an academic predominantly white institution, is the threats to self-integrity that they're continually confronting day-to-day in the form of microaggressions,
珀蒂·格林威（Purdy Greenway）、乔纳森·库克（Jonathan Cook）和我很多年前所做的一些工作，至少我们很多年前就开始了，而且我们现在仍在继续。它很大程度上借鉴了克劳德·斯蒂尔（Claude Steele）的自我肯定研究，该研究基本指出：人们在生活中努力做的一件事，就是维护自己作为具有全球胜任力、具备道德和适应能力的全面胜任者的形象。当然，人们希望感受到自己拥有自我完整性。而作为历史上被刻板印象化或污名化群体的一员，例如在以白人为主的学术机构中的非洲裔美国人或拉丁裔学生，其困难之处在于他们日复一日不断面临着对自我完整性的威胁，这些威胁表现为微攻击、
very typical messages, teacher expectations. So, you know, given the world as it is, you know, while we're still pushing the cultural ball forward to rid our institutions of bias and prejudice and these overt and sometimes subtle acts of bias, what can we do to armor people against the threats to self-integrity that they experience day to day? And one answer is these values affirmation activities. And with values affirmations, what we do is we kind of create a sort of safe situational space for students to assert what they value, their core values, and to reflect on why they're important to them. And so the way that this typically works is in a classroom, the teacher will ask kids to complete a writing activity
非常典型的言论以及教师的期望。所以，鉴于世界本来的样子，在我们继续推动文化大发展以消除我们机构中的偏见、歧视以及这些公开和有时微妙的偏见行为的同时，我们能做些什么来武装人们，抵御他们日复一日经历的对自我完整性的威胁呢？答案之一就是这些价值观肯定活动。在价值观肯定活动中，我们所做的是为学生创造一种安全的情境空间，让他们宣示自己的价值观，即他们的核心价值观，并反思为什么这些价值观对他们很重要。这种方法的典型运作方式是，在课堂上，老师会要求孩子们完成一项写作活动，
where they circle their most important values and then they just write about. Why are my values so important? And what that does is it sends the message to kids that, hey, I have a voice here. What I care about is recognize and acknowledge in the classroom. My teacher cares about it. Eric Smith has some really nice research showing that that's the message that these sorts of activities send. And then the student sort of shores up their self-sense of identity and self-integrated by asserting what's most important to them.
在活动中，他们圈出自己最重要的价值观，然后写下：为什么我的价值观如此重要？这样做向孩子们传递的信息是：嘿，在这里我有发言权。我在乎的东西在课堂上得到了认可和承认。我的老师很在乎它。埃里克·史密斯（Eric Smith）的一些非常棒的研究表明，这就是这类活动所传递的信息。然后，学生通过宣示对自己最重要的是什么，来巩固他们的自我认同感和自我完整性。
It's kind of a way to ground ourselves in these situations where we can kind of get a little, feel a little under assault, a little battered about one way to deal is to just ground ourselves in our most important values. And what we found in a lot of other researchers have found is that this small but potent act of reflecting on core values can sometimes under certain conditions have pretty positive benefits, including increasing GPA and college prospects of minority youth years and years later. A little small thing at the right time can have a big effect. So I want to change the topic a little bit and talk about political polarization, something that's been in the news a lot lately, especially as another election season approaches. And one section of your book describes how people's need to belong drives are political behavior and beliefs. How are issues around belonging contributing to political polarization?
这是一种在这些情境中让我们脚踏实地的方法，在这些情境中我们有时会受到一些攻击，感到有些受挫，应对的方法之一就是让我们立足于最重要的价值观。我们以及许多其他研究人员发现，这种反思核心价值观的小而有力的行为，有时在特定条件下会产生非常积极的益处，包括几年甚至多年后少数族裔青年的GPA和大学前景有所提高。在正确的时间做一件小事可以产生巨大的效果。所以我想稍微改变一下话题，谈谈政治两极分化，这是最近新闻中经常出现的话题，尤其是随着又一个选举季的临近。你书中的一个章节描述了人们对归属感的需求如何驱动他们的政治行为和信念。关于归属感的问题是如何导致政治两极分化的？
We live in an era where there is, as Pete Buttigieg put it, a crisis of belonging. The usual sources of belonging, such as religious affiliations, church, the workplace, family, extended family, those are kind of not as robust as they used to be. So there's a crisis of belonging. And as a result of that, people are finding identity and belonging in political tribes to some degree. And what that does is it can make people new religious in terms of their adherence to the positions of their political party. one of the things that is contributing to political polarization is the need to belong, that a lot of times people gain a sense of belonging by identifying with their political party,
我们生活在一个正如皮特·布蒂吉格（Pete Buttigieg）所说的那样存在“归属感危机”的时代。通常的归属感来源，比如宗教信仰、教会、职场、家庭、大家庭，已经不如以前那么稳固了。因此，存在着归属感危机。其结果是，人们在某种程度上在政治部落中寻找身份认同和归属感。这样做产生的影响是，在坚持其政党立场方面，人们可能会变得像宗教信徒一样狂热。导致政治两极分化的原因之一就是对归属感的需求，很多时候，人们通过认同自己的政党来获得归属感，
embracing its positions, even when it may be dangerous or ridiculous to do so. So to give one example of this, in some early research that we did on what we called the party over policy effect. We simply gave Democrats and Republicans a description of a welfare policy that was either very generous in its benefits or really draconian in its benefits. And then we asked Democrats and Republicans, you know, which policy do you support? How much do you support it? And as you might expect, Republicans like the more draconian policy, Democrats like the more generous policy. However, for a separate group of subjects, we told them, that Democratic lawmakers supported the draconian policy and Republican lawmakers supported the generous
拥护其立场，甚至在这样做可能很危险或荒谬时也是如此。为了说明这一点，在我们早期关于所谓的“政党高于政策效应”的研究中，我们只是向民主党人和共和党人提供了一份福利政策的描述，该政策的福利要么非常丰厚，要么非常严苛。然后我们询问民主党人和共和党人，你们支持哪项政策？你们支持的程度如何？正如你所料，共和党人喜欢更严苛的政策，民主党人喜欢更丰厚的政策。然而，对于另一组受试者，我们告诉他们，民主党议员支持严苛的政策，而共和党议员支持丰厚的
policy. And so the question was, what would drive people's attitude towards the policy? Would it be the content of the policy or the perceived position of their political party? And the answer was the perceived position of their political party. People went with their party, even when it defied ideological content or the factual content of the policy, that the position of their party trumped the impact of the policy content. So that was a kind of early demonstration. Wow, how the degree to which people conform their views to the position of valued reference groups, it seems to be a really powerful effect. And as you might imagine, of course, sometimes it's very rational to do this. Like, our groups are who we trust. And maybe
政策。所以问题是，是什么驱动了人们对政策的态度？是政策的内容，还是他们对政党立场的感知？答案是他们对政党立场的感知。人们追随自己的政党，即使这违背了政策的思想内容或事实内容，他们政党的位置也压倒了政策内容的影响。所以这是一个早期的证明。哇，人们将自己的观点与受人尊重的参考群体的立场保持一致的程度，似乎是一个非常强大的效应。正如你可以想象的那样，有时这样做当然是非常理性的。比如，我们的群体是我们信任的人。也许
it makes sense for Democrats to give heavy weight to what democratic lawmakers think. But the problem is, if we can't even agree on a policy that is really congenial to our ideological beliefs, if we can't even agree on the most congenial policy when it's proposed by our political adversaries, what could we ever agree on? That raises the idea that I've been toying within my head, which is that the idea of belonging is sort of a two-edge sword. I mean, the word itself, has a positive connotation, but many people have used the lure of belonging to convince people to do things that aren't really in their best interest and might be harmful or cruel or illegal. So how can individuals be more aware of when and how they're being manipulated by this need?
民主党人高度重视民主党议员的看法是有道理的。但问题是，如果我们甚至无法就一项非常符合我们意识形态信念的政策达成一致，如果我们甚至无法在政治对手提出时就最合拍的政策达成一致，我们还能就什么达成一致呢？这就提出了一个一直在我的脑海中萦绕的想法，那就是归属感其实是一把双刃剑。我的意思是，这个词本身带有积极的含义，但许多人利用归属感的诱惑来游说人们做一些并不真正符合他们最大利益的事情，甚至可能是恶劣的、残酷的或非法的。那么，个人如何才能更好地意识到他们何时以及如何被这种需求所操纵？
I don't think there's enough research on this, but for sure, one thing to watch out for is when you're with your own group or when you're thinking of your own group, what social psychologists call your reference group. It is one of the enduring messages of social psychology is that groups are a powerful part of our situations. Groups as Stanley Schachter, one of the sort of wizards of social psychology put it, exert pressures to uniformity. And a lot of the classic social psychology studies are demonstrations of this, that people will conform their judgments even when it defies the evidence of their own senses, to some degree, to some degree. So I do think one answer your question is just being aware of the power of group influence on us.
我认为对此的研究还不够，但可以肯定的是，需要注意的一点是，当你和自己的群体在一起时，或者当你想到自己的群体时，即社会心理学家所说的你的参考群体时。社会心理学持久的信息之一就是，群体是我们情境中强有力的组成部分。正如社会心理学界的奇才斯坦利·沙赫特（Stanley Schachter）所说，群体对同质性施加了压力。许多经典的社会心理学研究都证明了这一点，即人们会调整自己的判断，甚至在某种程度上违背自己感官的证据。因此，我确实认为回答你问题的一个答案就是，意识到群体影响力对我们的力量。
I think that's the first step is knowing that we're susceptible, understanding that we're susceptible. And we see this time and again in a lot of research, not only by us, but by Emily Pronin and others, is that the people who are often the least biased and the most able to break free of the influence of group pressures and other biases on their judgments are the people who recognize. that their introspection can be flawed. It's the people who have confidence in their own objectivity who paradoxically or ironically often prove the most susceptible to bias and group pressures. So I do think that just simply being aware,
我认为第一步是知道我们是脆弱的，理解我们是脆弱的。我们在许多研究中屡次看到这一点，不仅是我们自己的研究，还有艾米丽·普罗宁（Emily Pronin）等人的研究，那些往往最没有偏见、最能摆脱群体压力和其他偏见对判断影响的人，恰恰是那些认识到自己的内省可能存在缺陷的人。那些对自己的客观性充满信心的人，往往自相矛盾或具有讽刺意味地证明自己最容易受到偏见和群体压力的影响。所以我确实认为，仅仅是保持这种意识，
it's like that old Richard Feynman quote. I'm going to paraphrase it. The first mandate is do not deceive yourself in science and you are the easiest to deceive. I love that. It applies not just to science, but to social life. First principle, don't deceive yourself. You are the easiest to deceive. It is so easy for our thoughts to be contaminated by stereotypes, by group pressures, by whatnot. And the first step to trying to have some agency over their influence on us is just to be aware of their impact. You mentioned earlier the idea that there's a crisis of belonging. It might sound
就像理查德·费曼（Richard Feynman）的那句名言。我将对其进行释义。在科学中，第一条戒律是不要欺骗你自己，而你是最容易被欺骗的人。我喜欢这句话。它不仅适用于科学，也适用于社会生活。第一原则，不要欺骗自己。你是最容易被欺骗的。我们的思想太容易被刻板印象、群体压力等因素污染了。而试图对它们对我们的影响施加某种主导权的第一步，就是意识到它们的影响。你之前提到过存在归属感危机的观点。这可能听起来
familiar to some listeners. I mean, even the book bowling alone came out, right, about 20 years ago, and people have been talking for decades about how Americans are more isolated and lonely than ever and less connected to our communities. Do you think those worries are warranted? Do we actually feel less belonging than we used to? There's talk of an epidemic of loneliness, and the figures aren't as high as commonly conveyed. A lot of reports on the media say it's like 50% of people are suffering from severe loneliness. The figure is more like 20%, which is still a lot. Loneliness, prolonged and chronic loneliness is a national problem. Our Surgeon General has made it, you know, in his interviews and in his book together, he's made it clear that this is really a major national
对某些听众来说很熟悉。我的意思是，甚至像《独自打保龄球》这本书也是在大约20年前出版的，几十年来人们一直在谈论美国人比以往任何时候都更加孤立和孤独，与我们的社区联系更少。你认为这些担忧是有根据的吗？我们真的比过去感到更缺乏归属感吗？有人谈论孤独流行病，而且这些数字并不像通常传达的那样高。媒体上的许多报道称，大约有50%的人正遭受严重的孤独。而实际数字更接近20%，这仍然很多。孤独，长期且慢性的孤独是一个国家问题。我们的美国外科医生总会在他的采访和他的著作《在一起》中明确表示，这确实是一场重大的国家
crisis now. The sense that people have of being disconnected, not just from their community, not just from their country, but from the rest of humanity. Loneliness is a major crisis, both in our country and in other countries. So I think it is a huge problem now. It's a huge problem now for a lot of different reasons. I mean, the word, I feel like the word loneliness doesn't really capture the depth and severity of the despair. It is really an awful psychological state to be in one of the most noxious, one of the most notches. Going back to the earlier part of our conversation, we've evolved to go with our group. And so one of the worst things our central nervous system can communicate to the rest of our bodies is you are
危机。人们感到脱节，不仅与他们的社区脱节，不仅与他们的国家脱节，而且与全人类脱节。孤独是我们国家和其他国家的重大危机。所以我认为它现在是一个巨大的问题。由于许多不同的原因，它现在是一个巨大的问题。我的意思是，这个词，我觉得孤独这个词并没有真正捕捉到绝望的深度和严重性。这确实是一种糟糕的心理状态，是最有害、最令人讨厌的状态之一。回到我们对话的早期部分，我们进化出了追随群体的本能。因此，我们的中枢神经系统可以向身体其余部分传达的最糟糕的事情之一就是：你
alone. And there's an increasing amount of research that suggests that lacking social connection is as bad for us as smoking a pack of cigarettes today. It is one of the most, it's an awful environmental toxin. And when we go, you know, say to a new house, we are often thinking about, well, what about the radon, right? Let's get a radon to make sure we're not being exposed to some radioactive substance. We don't really think about these invisible social psychological toxins like loneliness and isolation, which just are incredibly noxious. Deaton case had provided pretty strong evidence that, you know, in recent years, there has been a huge increase in what they refer to as deaths of despair. People dying through suicide or addiction or overdose, and they
孤身一人。越来越多的研究表明，缺乏社会联系对我们的危害就像今天抽一包烟一样大。它是最严重的环境毒素之一。当我们搬到一个新房子时，我们经常会考虑，氡气怎么办？让我们检测一下氡气，以确保我们没有暴露在某些放射性物质中。我们并没有真正考虑这些无形的社会心理毒素，比如孤独和孤立，它们是极其有害的。迪顿和凯斯（Deaton-Case）提供了非常有力的证据，证明近年来，被称为绝望之死的人数大幅增加。人们因自杀、成瘾或过量服用而死，他们
link, I think it's about 180,000 cases deaths per year. They link this to social pain. So I think it's a big problem. And I think a lot of the problems that are besieging our nation, from racism to xenophobia to poor health to political polarization, to some degree have a common origin in this crisis of belonging that is roiling our society and other societies. So during the pandemic, many people's lives have moved online. Their work, they're socializing, school. Does interacting virtually rather than in person change how people experience belonging and could the move to remote offices for, example, make it more difficult for people to develop a sense of belonging at work or, you know, at school? I think so. There's not a lot of research on that yet, but it does seem to be the case that not having those face-to-face encounters is a corrosive agent to our connections. And the great
将此与社会痛苦联系起来，我认为大约每年有18万起死亡病例。他们将其与社会痛苦联系起来。所以我认为这是一个大问题。我认为困扰我们国家的许多问题，从种族主义到仇外心理，到健康状况不佳，再到政治两极分化，在某种程度上都起源于这场正在扰乱我们社会和其他社会的归属感危机。因此，在疫情期间，许多人的生活转移到了线上。他们的工作、社交、学校。与面对面相比，虚拟互动是否改变了人们对归属感的体验？例如，转向远程办公是否会使人们更难在工作中或学校里培养归属感？
resignation, though, it comes from, it has some understandable origins may have this side effect of cutting people off from even more, even further from the sense of belonging that they get from having a meaningful job with colleagues. Not that that was always the case before. I mean, people were right, you know, there's all, one of the things that is really important is that, yeah, workplaces, face-to-face workplaces could do a lot more to encourage a sense of belonging among their employees, ranging from acknowledging and appreciating their contributions to giving them more, giving employees more autonomy and sense of influence and voice
我认为是的。虽然对此的研究还不多，但没有这些面对面的交往似乎确实是对我们联系的一种侵蚀剂。而大辞职潮，尽管它有一些可以理解的根源，但可能会产生这样的副作用：将人们与从与有意义的工作和同事相处中获得的归属感进一步隔绝。并不是说以前总是这样。我的意思是，人们是对的，其中一件非常重要的事情是，工作场所，面对面的工作场所可以做更多的事情来鼓励员工之间的归属感，从承认和赞赏他们的贡献，到给员工更多的自主权以及对他们产品的更多的影响力和发言权，
over their products. But you are absolutely right that as we become. increasingly isolated because of this digital world we're in, belonging is going to be something that is harder for many of us to achieve, especially perhaps introverts, new research suggests, might have a harder time, creating those bonds of connection that they need. Also, there's a lot of tension now to social media as our lives migrate more and more onto these online platforms, social media platforms. That turns out to be a pretty corrosive agent to our sense of belonging, especially for young people. I mean, of course, of course, Facebook, Instagram, Twitter are ways
但你说得完全正确，随着我们因为身处这个数字世界而变得日益孤立，归属感将成为我们许多人更难实现的事情，新研究表明，特别是内向的人可能会觉得更难建立他们所需的连接纽带。此外，随着我们的生活越来越多地迁移到这些在线平台、社交媒体平台上，人们现在对社交媒体给予了极大的关注。事实证明，这对于我们的归属感来说是一个相当具有腐蚀性的因素，特别是对年轻人而言。我的意思是，当然，Facebook、Instagram、Twitter是
to connect us, of course. But on average, they seem to be not such a good thing, especially for young people, undermining their well-being, making them people less involved in the kinds of civic and face-to-face associations that we know encourage a sense of belonging and purpose, one of the big contributors to mental and physical health. So I think that that's another corrosive agent to belonging. There's some nice research by Liz Dunn out of Liz Dunn's lab, just showing that even having our phones out during a dinnertime conversation makes us less present, less likely to enjoy the company of friends and family.
连接我们的方式，当然。但平均而言，它们似乎并不是什么好东西，尤其是对年轻人而言，它们破坏了他们的福祉，使他们更少参与那些我们知道能激发出归属感和目标感的公民和面对面社团——这是身心健康的主要贡献者之一。所以我认为这是对归属感的另一个腐蚀剂。利兹·邓恩（Liz Dunn）实验室有一些非常棒的研究表明，甚至在晚餐时间把手机拿出来，也会让我们不那么投入，不那么可能享受朋友和家人的陪伴。
So I do think that this is one of the major challenges of our errors, how to maintain that sense of connection, even as we're physically being pulled and mentally being pulled away from the situation as a result of social media and media and the increasingly digital nature of the environments we're living in. So what's next for you? What are you working on now? Well, one of the things that I am really interested in is not so much wise interventions per se, but how can you teach people, parents, teachers, mentors to embody the lessons of social psychology
所以我确实认为，这是我们这个时代的主要挑战之一，如何在即使我们在物理上和心理上由于社交媒体、媒体以及我们生活的环境中日益数字化的性质而被从情境中拉开的情况下，依然保持这种连接感。那么你接下来要做什么？你现在在研究什么？嗯，我真正感兴趣的不是明智的干预措施本身，而是如何教导人们——父母、老师、导师，在日常交往中体现社会心理学的教训。
in their day-to-day encounters? And one of the big ideas, I think here is that we are in ways more than we appreciate molders of other people's psychology, and we have the ability to create connection down on the ground in our day-to-day encounters in surprisingly powerful ways. I think that's the message of a lot of this research. Just simply acknowledging that you see a person through, say, wise criticism or values affirmation can have powerful lasting effects. So given that, given that these little one-off interventions can, under certain circumstances, have such large and lasting effects, the possibilities of creating even more meaningful, systemic, widespread change, capture the imagination. If only one thing can do that, what could we do? if we had not so much an arsenal of wise interventions, but the wisdom of practice, knowing
在其中发挥作用。我认为这里的一个核心观点是，我们在比自己所意识到的更多的方面塑造着他人的心理，并且我们有能力在日常交往中以令人惊讶的强大方式在基层建立联系。我认为这就是许多研究传达的信息。仅仅是通过诸如明智的批评或价值观肯定等方式承认你看到了一个人，就能产生强大而持久的影响。因此，鉴于这些微小的一次性干预措施在特定情况下可以产生如此巨大而持久的影响，创造更有意义、系统性、广泛的变革的可能性吸引了人们的想象力。如果只有一件事能做到这一点，如果我们不仅拥有明智干预措施的武器库，而且拥有实践的智慧，知道如何去做，我们能做些什么呢？
how to create connection in our day-to-day encounters with people with whom we disagree, with our students, with clients, with friends. I really, really believe that we have a lot to learn. I know I have learned so much by studying what I study. There's so much that we can do to break free of these harmful biases and cultural programming that undermines our ability to create connections and bridge divides. Well, Dr. Cohen, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. And I would encourage our listeners also to pick up your book.
如何在与我们意见不合的人、我们的学生、客户以及朋友的日常交往中建立联系。我真的、真的相信我们有很多东西要学。我知道通过研究我所研究的内容，我学到了很多。我们可以做很多事情来摆脱这些有害的偏见和文化编程，正是它们破坏了我们建立联系和弥合分歧的能力。科恩博士，我想感谢你今天能来。这真的非常有趣。我也鼓励我们的听众去买你的书。
It's very engaging. I don't always plug my guest books, but I think yours is very readable. And I think our listeners would enjoy it. Thank you. Thank you, Kim. I really appreciate it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website. at www.
这本书非常引人入胜。我并不总是为我嘉宾的书做宣传，但我认为你的书读起来非常轻松愉快，我们的听众也会喜欢它。谢谢你，谢谢你，金。我真的非常感激。你可以在我们的网站上找到《心理学之声》往期的节目，网址是www.
www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts,
www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Stitcher以及你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，
you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association,
你可以通过电子邮件与我们联系：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学之声》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。